on that trip I'm visiting him at the
Mayo Clinic it's 2019 it's like March of
2019 and he has like his stomach has
filled up with fluid like he's in this
bed and I'm like why is his stomach so
big and they're like those fluid is just
building up so doing like stomach
draining it's crazy I know there's 20
tubes like you know you're seeing like
what is this exiting out of this tube
it's like black you know like just all
kinds of things going on with him
sideways and that's when like the doc
one of the doctors pulled me aside and
he was like he was like Hey man pussy's
[__] pussy's
[__]
sorry and I was like you're the second
doctor that said
that the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
sickler